there is something super interesting
going on in South Carolina where failed
former president Donald Trump is really
struggling to find state lawmakers
willing to show up at this stupid rally
event he has planned for this weekend
and support him on stage now let me kind
of remind you what's going on uh Trump's
running for president again in 2024 he
announced relatively early he basically
hasn't left his house since the
announcement in November but now he is
starting events one such event is in
South Carolina this weekend our
correspondent Luke Beasley is going to
be there he will be interviewing people
should be pretty interesting content
that we will have for you as a result
now Trump doesn't seem to be struggling
to get Federal level lawmakers who
represent South Carolina to go and stand
with him at the rally but the state
lawmakers are hilariously not super
thrilled about participating there is a
rolling stone article so sad Trump's
South Carolina rally getting little
support from State lawmakers despite
making numerous pleading phone calls the
former president's team is hitting a
wall in the state writes Peter Wade for
Rolling Stone The Washington Post
reports that Trump's team has been
making pleading phone calls to potential
supporters across the state but many are
responding with less than enthusiasm
because South Carolina lawmakers are not
yet ready to commit to a candidate
especially when two of the state's
Republicans are eyeing presidential runs
themselves that's South Carolina former
South Carolina Governor Nikki Haley and
current South Carolina Senator Tim Scott
the article also mentions Lindsey Graham
and Henry McMaster are expected to show
up and show support
um this is really really interesting
because if you look at polling in South
Carolina you find that the majority of
South Carolina's residents disapprove of
trump and to a certain degree it seems
as though the state politicians people
in the State House State Senate are
either on the same page in their
disapproval for Trump or are kind of
reading the tea leaves and saying well I
don't know that I want to get ahead of
myself and to support Trump and be
publicly seen and tied to Trump when
many of my constituents don't seem to be
big fans we don't even know if Trump
will be the nominee we don't know what
things will look like come next year and
so you end up with this situation where
only five of the state's Republican
senators and representatives are
publicly supporting Trump some uh like
Jeff Duncan are pushing back against his
policies and has have been critical of
Trump's trade policy for example or have
said Trump hasn't been doing the right
things to make the immigration system
more fair or whatever the case may be
and then some some State reps from South
Carolina have gone even further than
simply not voicing support you've got
for example like Nancy mace who is
trying to pass legislation that
undermines some of Trump's policy ideas
like she wants to protect so-called
dreamers from deportation whereas Trump
was open to deporting dreamers so this
is potentially going to be a problem for
Trump as this campaign tries to get
going there have been advisors to Trump
just blanketing South Carolina trying to
find people to come and support him and
the important thing to remember and we
learned this from the Democratic primary
just because a candidate can have a
rally with a few thousand people
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
are well-liked Statewide and you know
one of the things we experienced during
the Democratic primary was that if you
based your estimates of support for
Bernie Sanders based on Twitter and
Reddit and I was one of his supporters
you had a much inflated uh sense of
Bernie's support within the Democratic
party and then when voting actually
started taking place you got a very
different sense and we know ultimately
how that went down that all being said
the polls as we reviewed yesterday are
still looking pretty good for Trump in
the Republican primary there was a
period there in early December where Ron
DeSantis was really doing quite well in
the polling but it does appear at least
right now that Donald Trump has a
commanding lead in just about every
Republican primary poll of substance
that being said nobody else has
announced Trump is being put up in polls
against people who aren't even
officially running yet and that could
mean something quite different once we
get more announcements so we're going to
follow it I will not be covering the
rally this weekend I'm actually going to
be away
um but Luke Beasley is going to be there
and then we'll have clips for when I am
back one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zippix brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipx has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and Cafe fiend toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx toothpicks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below